[Música]
tomó por sorpresa a la comunidad
internacional la excarcelación y
posteriormente el destierro de 222
presos políticos en Nicaragua es
considerado desde ya por muchos
analistas como el fin y también el
inicio de un nuevo capítulo en la crisis
política de Nicaragua así daba a conocer
la liberación y los delitos por los que
fueron declarados desterrados por parte
de las autoridades nicaragüenses
escuchemos los deportados fueron
declarados traidores a la patria y
sancionados por diferentes delitos
graves e inhabilitados de forma perpetua
para ejercer la función pública En
nombre del Servicio del Estado de
Nicaragua así como ejercer cargos de
elección popular la decisión fue tomada
de manera unilateral por el gobierno de
Daniel Ortega aclaró que si bienes
fueron enviados y recibidos por Estados
Unidos no hubo ningún tipo de
negociación entre las partes la idea de
Ortega es muy simple expulsarlos
alejarlos y garantizar que no regresen a
suelo nicaragüense cuando llegaron
llegaron a preguntar que
qué interés teníamos nosotros ninguno
que se lo llevan Eso es todo
O sea no se trataba de negociar
aquí no ha habido ninguna negociación
esto debe quedar claro
porque la soberanía del país
la dignidad de la patria
no se negocia los hechos tuvieron lugar
muy rápidamente el gobierno nicaragüense
tomó la decisión de liberarlos e
inmediatamente comunicó su decisión de
desterrarlos a este grupo de opositores
hacia los Estados Unidos las
instituciones locales entonces emitieron
rápidamente pasaportes para que los
detenidos pudieran entrar a territorio
de Estados Unidos bajo una figura
migratoria llamada el Parral humanitario
que les permite estar en ese país
norteamericano Por espacio de dos años
mientras su situación migratoria tiene
una definición por parte de las
autoridades de Estados Unidos pero
Estados Unidos no fue el único país que
abrió la puerta a este grupo de los 222
expulsados el reino de España también
ofreció otorgarles la ciudadanía de ese
país europeo escuchemos el gobierno se
felicita ante la decisión de liberar a
222 presos de las en Nicaragua también
nos ofrecemos a que España acoja a
cualquier otro preso que se encuentre
todavía en estos momentos en la misma
situación que estos que acaban de ser
liberados y les anunció que el gobierno
ofrece la nacionalidad española a estos
222 presos liberados ante las noticias
de que se ha iniciado el trámite para
declararles apátridas algunos de los 222
liberados ya han podido reencontrarse
con sus familiares algunos tienen
opciones para volver a empezar sus vidas
desde cero también Establecer un rumbo y
si lo desean o no seguir con sus
reclamos hacia el gobierno de Daniel
Ortega como democráticamente se supone
que debe ser posible pero hay un sector
de la sociedad nicaragüense también de
la diáspora que vive por ejemplo en
Estados Unidos también buena parte de la
comunidad internacional que está a la
expectativa por la suerte que pueda
tener el obispo católico Rolando Álvarez
crítico del gobierno de Ortega que fue
liberado pero se rehusó a abordar ese
vuelo rumbo a Estados Unidos y fue
condenado Entonces por las autoridades
nicaragüenses a 26 años y cuatro meses
de prisión se trata entonces de el más
reciente golpe de la justicia
nicaragüense contra algún tipo de
crítico del gobierno qué le espera
Entonces al obispo Álvarez Y de ahí pues
se desprenden múltiples preguntas qué
sigue ahora para este grupo de 222
liberados que sigue ahora para los
nicaragüenses que se quedan en el país
que sigue también entonces para el
gobierno de Daniel Ortega Qué
consecuencias trae este acto para el
gobierno de Ortega Murillo y que sigue
para las luchas de los opositores para
también que sigue para la democracia
nicaragüense si se le puede llamar así
lo que viene y lo que sigue en este
nuevo capítulo de la crisis política de
Nicaragua es nuestro punto central de
debate aquí en France 24 para analizar
este tema hemos invitado a Ana María
Méndez tardón ella es directora para
Centroamérica de bola y también hemos
contactado a Kevin Solís quien es un
Expreso político allí en Nicaragua es
uno de los 222 liberados ahí lo ven
ustedes en imágenes desde la ciudad de
Washington en un automóvil Está tratando
de llegar a un punto para poder
conectarse con nosotros y ser parte del
programa pero vamos a tenerlos a los dos
conectados para conversar sobre lo que
sigue para Nicaragua en este resto de
semanas ustedes Recuerden que también
pueden dejar sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter en Facebook y también
en instagram nos encuentran como arroba
franz24_es la etiqueta para que dejen
los comentarios es numeral el debate f24
todo junto mi cuenta personal arroba
santilogo no olviden también que los
contenidos están disponibles en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
Pues muy bien continuó entonces
preguntándole a Ana María la percepción
que deja esta decisión del gobierno de
Nicaragua esta Liberación este destierro
y esta llegada a territorio
estadounidense Ana María Gracias por
estar con nosotros en el programa
adelante su perspectiva
Muchísimas gracias por la invitación
Pues vale la pena anotar que este es un
gran importante paso desde el punto de
vista humanitario sin embargo
cabe mencionar que esto no garantiza que
se abra un diálogo para la
democratización del país
ni tampoco para detener las graves
violaciones a derechos humanos que
siguen ocurriendo en Nicaragua
Claro que la comunidad internacional
celebra la liberación de estos presos
políticos pero también
recalcamos que esto No necesariamente se
trata de una liberación de presos
políticos con base alguna negociación
como el mismo gobierno de Ortega lo
mencionó sino más bien es un
desplazamiento forzado es una
excarcelación y una expulsión de cierto
grupo de nicaragüenses muy importante
para el país estamos hablando de 222
personas en las cuales hay líderes y de
la oposición política periodistas
independientes defensoras y Defensores
de Derechos Humanos entre otras personas
que fueron excarcelados en el pasado
jueves nueve de febrero
la perspectiva de Ana María como Punto
de partida para el programa le doy la
bienvenida ahora a Kevin me confirman si
tenemos la conexión con él para para
conversar con él a Kevin Entonces lo
saludo en la ciudad de Washington es uno
de los liberados en este en este grupo
de 222 personas y que fueron expulsados
de Nicaragua Kevin su opinión Cómo
recibió usted esta noticia ser puesto
ahora en libertad y estar en Estados
Unidos en cuestión de horas su vida
cambió por completo pasar de una prisión
nicaragüense a estar en Estados Unidos
en completa libertad
No claro
cambió bastante estamos retenidos en
máxima seguridad en aislamiento dicen
que vamos libre una transición
totalmente diferente increíble muchos ya
hemos perdido la esperanza pero Dios
abrió las puertas pues para un cambio
ahora
asimilando un poco el cambio radical y
esperando a ver qué sucede
Por qué cree usted que el gobierno de
Nicaragua tomó esta decisión porque
liberarlos en este momento en la
coyuntura que vive el país en este
momento Y por qué ustedes
yo personalmente lo que creo es tratando
de entablar él una negociación aunque él
diga que no porque en realidad al
parecer sí lo quiere hacer porque a los
días de de nuestra Liberación el
cancillermo en cada estaba por acá en
Estados Unidos solicitando
alguna forma de hablar ya que se tiene
se tienen en consideración Estados
Unidos de empezar a poner sanciones más
más fuerte la economía de del régimen
Sí Ana María que se puede inferir de
esta de esta decisión unilateral del
gobierno de Nicaragua que qué motivos
pudo haber llevado a la administración
de Ortega a tomar esta decisión porque
había mucha presión ya a lo largo de los
últimos meses por parte de la comunidad
internacional sobre los los presos
políticos Pero esta decisión tomó por
sorpresa como lo decía yo al inicio del
programa tomó por sorpresa pues al mundo
entero
Sí desconocemos realmente
que hay detrás de toda esta decisión
podría ser un poco lo que se mencionó
anteriormente sobre las sanciones que
interpone que Interpuesto el gobierno de
los Estados Unidos especialmente las
sanciones financieras que podrían
golpear la economía
nicaragüense y que por ahí podría haber
un motivo detrás efectivamente hubo toda
una presión de distintos colectivos
especialmente de organizaciones
internacionales en derechos humanos para
la liberación de presos políticos y
probablemente también esto sea producto
de esa de esas campañas que se hicieron
desde el punto de vista humanitario para
la liberación de presos políticos cabe
recordar que el mismo departamento de
estado anunció en un comunicado que sí
tuvo comunicación con el canciller
Moncada y el mismo gobierno de los
Estados Unidos estableció literalmente
que la liberación de presos políticos ha
marcado un paso constructivo para
abordar la situación de los Derechos
Humanos
en Nicaragua y también para abrir una
puerta al diálogo que digamos que sería
lo más importante en este momento Kevin
cree usted que esto es el primer paso
para una puerta hacia el diálogo como
dice Ana María hay una forma de de
empezar a conversar con el régimen de el
presidente Ortega allí en Nicaragua y
esto le puede jugar en contra al
presidente esta decisión o esto le juega
a favor
Bueno a favor es con una espada doble
filo a favor porque le estaría
demostrando de que un acto de buena
voluntad de que sí quiero un proceso de
diálogo pero también está el tema de que
Ortega ha demostrado en el pasado de que
él le gusta jugar bajo presión también o
sea que tengo esta moneda aquí y si no
no llega un diálogo esto los mantengo
preso pero al habernos liberado le puede
servir en contra
después servir en contra que estaría
Entonces negociando él estaría
negociando el final de esas sanciones
económicas para darle un alivio a la
economía de nicaragüense muy golpeada no
solamente por las sanciones
internacionales sino también por el
contexto Mundial de la recuperación post
a pandemia de Kobe 19 O estaría él
negociando algo para él y su esposa una
vez dejé en el poder
creo que más para el sanción porque no
creo que se vayan a retirar ahorita
según lo que tengo entendido Incluso en
Nicaragua ya hay rumores pero solo
rumores de que están preparando personas
tu hijo o familia para seguir en el
poder y creo que es por las sanciones
porque las sanciones la economía de
Nicaragua sigue golpeada está bastante
golpeada creo que el tema de sanciones
que él está negociando no creo que sea
un tipo de perdón para él y su esposa
Ana María hablemos de la situación de
los derechos humanos en en Nicaragua la
presión internacional que ha habido a lo
largo de los últimos años a raíz de
estas de estas detenciones en el
contexto de las manifestaciones
ciudadanas y también de la campaña
presidencial
Fue suficiente o no Esa presión
internacional para para
llegar a este escenario porque tomó
tiempo llegar hasta Liberación no fue
algo tan inmediato como se como se
esperaba con respecto a la liberación de
los de los presos políticos sobre todo
por aquellos que estaban siendo acusados
por unos delitos que no habían cometido
Sí así es creo que también ha tenido
algún impacto que líderes de la
izquierda latinoamericana pues como el
caso del presidente Petro en Colombia
pues hayan elevado la voz a digamos a
esta crisis humanitaria y Derechos
Humanos que ha sufrido Nicaragua en los
últimos años Yo quiero anotar aquí dos
cosas importantes y uno es que no hay
que olvidar que pese a esta Liberación
Como un buen paso o un paso importante
la represión en Nicaragua continúa la
situación grave
de Derechos Humanos sigue siendo algo
que está afectando a la mayoría de la
población no olvidemos que hasta la
fecha
el régimen de Ortega Murillo ha
cancelado tres mil doscientas
organizaciones sin fines de lucro
ha atacado a la prensa independiente y
algo tan importante también que no se ha
mencionado ahora es que con la excar de
estas 222 personas él le quitó la
nacionalidad
nicaragüense a los prisioneros políticos
esto es grave porque atenta contra los
Derechos Humanos la misma declaración
universal de derechos humanos y la
convención americana de Derechos Humanos
garantiza el derecho a la nacionalidad
como un derecho humano Entonces es
importante que no dejemos de vista no no
perdamos de vista el la vulnerabilidad
en la que sigue estando la la población
nicaragüense ante estos graves abusos de
poder que está cometiendo el régimen de
Ortega de Murillo y para finalizar Solo
recordemos que esta medida de quitarle
la nacionalidad podría impactar a
muchísimos nicaragüenses en el exilio
pero también a la misma gente que ha
quedado en el país
esto sumaba que sí adelante
también que en el 2021 la asamblea hizo
una reforma para incorporar delitos con
los cuales ellos persiguen a cualquier
voz disidentes delitos como terrorismo o
el mismo delito que se le ha Interpuesto
al mismo arzobispo Ronaldo Álvarez que
es por traición a la patria Sí Ana María
en ese contexto entonces la ley Cómo
puede proteger a estas personas que
fueron despojadas de su nacionalidad
además que también trae sobre la mesa el
presidente Ortega unas acciones que son
casi me atrevería yo a decir medievales
como son el destierro Esto no se veía
desde hace muchísimo tiempo atrás no es
practicado por ningún otro país
en el mundo como como esto puede
Cómo se puede proteger a estas personas
que no tienen nacionalidad y que fuera
de eso están desterradas
si no hay un precedente realmente con
este caso es es complejo pero creo que
desde la perspectiva del derecho
internacional de los Derechos Humanos
hay formas para garantizar el derecho a
la nacionalidad a estas personas el
mismo gobierno Pues de Estados Unidos o
el gobierno de España pues han ofrecido
el apoyo humanitario necesario para
estas personas que quedan sin sin
nacionalidad identidad entonces Habría
que ver No desde el desde los distintos
recursos que que se ofrecen tanto en el
derecho internacional derechos humanos
como toda la protección a refugiados o a
las personas perseguidas por causas
políticas Pues habrá una salida ahí pero
insistimos es una es una queda todavía
un estado de vulnerabilidad
especialmente a la gente que está en el
país Kevin paso a preguntarle a usted
qué decisión ha tomado usted para
comenzar de nuevo su vida Usted va a
permanecer en Estados Unidos o va a
aceptar el ofrecimiento del reino de
España de recibir la ciudadanía española
Qué plan tiene ahora para comenzar otra
vez su vida y y continuar
es quedarme en Estados Unidos y la
embajada española nos dijo que la
nacionalidad podíamos obtenerla incluso
estando dentro de Estados Unidos No
tendríamos que viajar hasta allá y
empezar de Cero en seguir exigiendo la
libertad de los del resto de precios que
quedan porque quedan precios políticos
de Nicaragua y siete millones de
secuestrados todavía que el país entero
donde no hay libertad de expresión ni
nada
un nuevo comienzo y
agradecido siempre con todas las
personas que nos han abierto la puerta
en este país y qué hay de su familia
usted todavía tiene familiares en
Nicaragua familiares que pueden de
pronto volver a ser blanco de esta
persecución o ya su familia también está
fuera del territorio de nicaragüense
mi familia está fuera el territorio
nicaragüense
bien Y qué perspectivas tiene entonces
usted para futuro en Estados Unidos qué
plantea Qué planea hacer seguir esta
lucha Y esta crítica hacia el gobierno
de Ortega desde que óptica desde qué
punto
No sí nos estamos coordinando con las
vías por nicaragüenses aquí en el
exterior para seguir luchando claro por
la por la libertad total de Nicaragua
para poder para que haya respeto pues a
los derechos humanos en Nicaragua
estamos organizándonos aún nos estamos
organizando todo nos estamos organizando
con los excandidatos con todos los que
fuimos liberados y con las vías
nicaragüenses
Ana María este grupo de 222 personas que
ahora están en la libertad que ahora se
encuentran en Estados Unidos o en otros
países y poco a poco se van a comenzar a
dispersar por otros territorios
van a empezar a alzar la voz algunos de
ellos así como Kevin ha dicho continúa
con con su posición y su crítica hacia
algunos planteamientos del gobierno de
Ortega y aquí ellos pueden alzar su voz
en cuanto a las detenciones arbitrarias
de las que fueron víctimas los maltratos
también las torturas a las que fueron
sometidos aquí no se le va a abrir un
capítulo muy complicado al presidente
Ortega en cuanto a denuncias que puede
haber y sobre todo porque estas personas
ya están fuera de territorio
nicaragüense y no habrá nadie que los
pueda silenciar allí no puede llegar la
mano represiva del Estado nicaragüense a
callarlos
Sí claro definitivamente Esas voces van
a tener un peso muy importante desde
fuera pero quisiera agregar que también
es importante que la comunidad
internacional y los organismos de
protección a derechos humanos se puedan
organizar para ellos también seguir
condenando lo que sucede en Nicaragua
hoy día quisiera mencionar que el seis
de marzo el grupo de expertos que fue
asignado por el consejo de derechos
humanos de Naciones Unidas presentará su
informe ante Ginebra sobre Nicaragua
ellos ven se suman tienen su mandato
termina en marzo y ellos pues
investigaron todas las graves
violaciones a derechos humanos que se
convirtieron en Nicaragua entonces no es
solo es la voz de los nicaragüenses en
el exilio sino también el respaldo que
tienen que tener estas voces desde
distintos organismos de protección como
la oea Naciones Unidas y el mismo
gobierno de Estados Unidos o el gobierno
de España que pueden respaldar estas
demandas de los personas en el exilio
Ana María me pareció importante
profundizar en un panorama que usted ya
estaba mencionando en una de sus
respuestas anteriores Y usted decía que
Nicaragua continúa la represión continúa
la persecución a los a los críticos del
gobierno a la iglesia a los medios de
comunicación que hay de la ciudadanía
Cómo se vive en Nicaragua el día de hoy
cómo es vivir en Nicaragua hoy
hay temor Hay muchísimo miedo hay
represión el como mencionaba
anteriormente el cierre de espacio
Cívico es tremendo el hecho que hayan
tres mil doscientas organizaciones sin
fines de lucro cerradas las cuales en su
mayoría fueron cerradas en el dos
muestra un panorama de cómo está la
libertad de expresión un un país en el
que alzar la voz Es es ponerse en riesgo
a una detención e inclusive una
ejecución extrajudicial es muy crítica
esta situación y también mencionar que
el dato Este de las tres mil doscientas
organizaciones sin fines de lucro nos
muestra como el régimen ha tratado de
desarticular El tejido social y
criminalizar cualquier voz disidente de
la ciudadanía nicaragüense Kevin Cómo
cree usted que se llegó a este escenario
Nicaragua en los primeros años del
gobierno de Ortega mostraba una economía
de crecimiento mostraba un país
integrado en la comunidad internacional
con su perspectiva de un gobierno de
izquierda pero integrado en el escenario
internacional y cómo se llegó a este
escenario de represión de tres mil y
tantas organizaciones sin ánimo de lucro
cerradas expulsiones exilio la
persecución medios de comunicación
cerrados radios locales cerradas qué fue
lo que sucedió en Nicaragua que generó
toda esta detonación
social y política y que la gente tenga
miedo hoy en día
el texto empezó el 18 de abril con la
con lo del seguro social no no
permitieron que la gente se manifestara
no querían que nadie expresara Lo que
siente el descontento en contra de las
violaciones y siguieron así Simplemente
sacaron su verdadero rostro ellos ya
eran así pero no habían quitado no
habían la gente se quitó la máscara y
ellos se quitaron también la máscara que
tenía la represión no ha parado no solo
eso También tenemos el sin número de de
de de de de de canales cerrados de
universidades que han sido amenazadas de
quitarles todo los movimientos de
Derechos Humanos impulsados del país y
los más de 300 muertos
la libertad de expresión está viciada en
Nicaragua no hay libertad de expresión
en la libertad de expresión Dejó de ser
un derecho para convertirse en un delito
Sí
qué hay de las fuerzas sandinistas el el
sandinismo porque también dentro de las
personas expulsadas del país dentro de
las personas desterradas hay algunos
integrantes de la antigua guerrilla
sandinista que lucharon hombro a hombro
con Daniel Ortega en su momento Bueno me
confirman que se ha caído la conexión
con Kevin y vamos a intentar retomarla
entonces más adelante dejo entonces para
hacerle esta pregunta de análisis a
Kevin un poco más adelante y le
preguntaron a María cómo está entonces
la cohesión del gobierno al interior del
país qué tanto apoyo recibió Ortega al
interior del país incluso dentro del
mismo sandinismo lo estaba mencionando
hace unos segundos algunos de los
expulsados del país eran integrantes de
la antigua guerrilla y comba hombro a
hombro con Daniel Ortega contra el
régimen de somoza y hoy en día están
desterrados
sí es es una pregunta difícil de
responder justamente por el clima de
represión que hay en Nicaragua es decir
cualquier intento de asociación para
manifestar y expresar realmente lo que
está sucediendo en el país pues es
silenciado por el gobierno de Ortega
Entonces no hay certeza digamos pero
evidentemente
sí pues conversaciones con con
nicaragüenses en el exilio y organismos
internacionales de protección Pues el
clima de temor y represión sigue siendo
algo muy fuerte que está dañando
grandemente especialmente a la población
vulnerable
en Nicaragua respecto a su pregunta del
del sandinismo y un poco el gobierno
Pues es que Ortega tiene el control de
de todos los poderes del Estado no hay
separación de poderes Entonces él las de
desarticulado no solo digamos ese
partido y lo que representaba
históricamente el frente sandinista para
nacional sino también la misma
institucionalidad que ahora está que
desarticuló los tres poderes del Estado
teniendo él el control absoluto de de
Nicaragua y que hay del apoyo a nivel
internacional también lo mencionaba hace
algunos años en los primeros años del
regreso de Daniel Ortega al poder pues
había un gran apoyo a nivel
internacional y Nicaragua era un país
integrado dentro de América Latina y
tenía
relación cercana con algunos países de
la región y tenía un buen desempeño
económico Cómo estar Nicaragua hoy en
día a nivel internacional quien se
relaciona con Nicaragua quien apoya
Nicaragua quien apoya Daniel Ortega
a ver a nivel de de tener socios
comerciales y
inclusive de apoyo militar estamos
hablando de China y Rusia que por
supuesto tienen una relación estrecha
con con el gobierno de Ortega y
obviamente otros gobiernos que también
son conocidos a nivel internacional por
por ser o dictaduras o por tener la
democracia en una fragilidad tremenda no
como el caso de de Venezuela
preocupa también el silencio de otros
líderes de la región especialmente en la
región centroamericana y es justamente
porque hay una tendencia no solo en el
caso de Nicaragua sino en otros países
de la región hacia la autoritarismo y lo
vemos como el caso de del presidente
nayib bukele en El Salvador en el que él
en el próximo año en Febrero que son las
elecciones Busca una reelección pese a
una prohibición constitucional Entonces
el fenómeno Ortega digamos Más allá de
los amigos que puede tener por
cuestiones de afinidad ideológica o o
cuestiones de de comercio
y económicas está esa tendencia que la
ha marcado en otros países de la región
que preocupa no la criminalización por
ejemplo
de operadores de Justicia independientes
en Guatemala es algo que sucede vemos
periodistas en la cárcel por los mismos
delitos que Ortega puso a periodistas en
la cárcel como el caso de José Rubén
Zamora y de Chamorro ambos acusados por
lavado de dinero y hoy José Rubén Zamora
en Guatemala
autodenominado preso político por el
gobierno ayamatei
es no sé si es cuestionable Ana María
mientras intentamos de restablecer la la
conexión con Kevin ver cómo a la
comunidad internacional el caso
Nicaragua comienza a salirse de las
manos o se le salió de las manos en
algún momento faltó un poco más de
presencia internacional de apretar un
poco más las tuercas para garantizar la
democracia la independencia de poderes
garantizar los Derechos Humanos a los
ciudadanos o simplemente el mundo le dio
la espalda a este país o bueno a los
ciudadanos en este caso
si yo creería que nunca se previó
el la magnitud de lo que esto iba a
llegar y tampoco hubo la certeza de que
esto iba a una escalada aún muchísimo
mayor entonces
un régimen autoritario lo primero que
hace es desconocer un orden
internacional entonces la comunidad
internacional Me parece que sí expresó
preocupación tú y tuvieron de algunas
iniciativas y medidas por ejemplo en el
caso de la oea que se instaló un
mecanismo para todo el tema de Derechos
Humanos pero en contextos en donde
un régimen se burla o simplemente
desconoce ese orden jurídico
internacional pues ya el contexto o la
habilidad que pueda tener una influencia
constructiva la comunidad internacional
queda muy limitada porque
no son tomadas en cuenta sus
observaciones por parte de estos
gobiernos pasa ahora en Guatemala la oea
Lamentablemente ha perdido
al igual que en el caso del Salvador por
ejemplo
yo sigue entonces para este país una
mayor presión a nivel internacional o
una mayor lupa vigilancia de la
comunidad internacional porque hay
algunos analistas que indican que este
tipo de acción tomada por el gobierno de
Ortega es un síntoma de debilidad y es
un momento de coyuntura para
aprovecharlo para retomar y encausar el
país en la senda democrática
yo creo que sí yo creo que sí es Es
complicado decir si realmente el
gobierno de Ortega tiene disponibilidad
o no al diálogo porque hemos visto
muchos mensajes confusos de parte de del
mismo gobierno de Ortega porque sí hubo
una comunicación por ejemplo con el
gobierno de Estados Unidos y el
cancillermo Moncada Pero por otro parte
el Si vemos las últimas declaraciones de
Ortega pues se muestra
no abierto a ningún tipo de de diálogo o
negociación con la comunidad
internacional
Pero sí yo creo que es una coyuntura que
se tiene que aprovechar y especialmente
para visibilizar la situación actual e
insistimos de represión temor y abusos
que que sigue viviendo el pueblo
nicaragüense Ana María Entonces en ese
orden de ideas por dónde empezar
yo creería que ahora el gobierno de
Estados Unidos tiene
Pues debería tomar la batuta al ser el
receptor digamos de estos doscientos
veintidós presos políticos y al tener
casi el 60% del de sus tratados de
comercio con con Nicaragua es decir hay
una cuestión contradictoria acá también
del mismo gobierno de Estados Unidos
pero es algo que es real Entonces al
tener esa
ese poder de negociación por y que
asumimos que en el fondo de de todo esto
el motivo ha sido no estar sujeto a
sanciones financieras por el gobierno de
Estados Unidos Pues liderar un diálogo
constructivo
entre el gobierno de de Ortega con con
el gobierno de Estados Unidos esto puede
servir de buen ejemplo si se le puede
decir así Ana María de un proceso que
lleve a un puerto positivo y que sirva
de ejemplo para
realizar esta misma estrategia con otro
país Como por ejemplo el caso de
Venezuela donde también se pide la
liberación de presos políticos y donde
también Hay muchísimas críticas al
gobierno de Nicolás maduro por las
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
Quisiera decir que sí yo creo que las
personas que trabajamos por los Derechos
Humanos tenemos esperanzas y no no
estaríamos en esto sin embargo lo veo
muy difícil ya hay un antecedente con
Cuba No recuerdo el año ahora
exactamente pero es una expulsión de 75
presos políticos hacia España en algún
momento Y eso No necesariamente
significó que se abriera una puerta la
democratización de Cuba es decir ya hay
un antecedente entonces esperamos que
esto no sea el caso y que realmente
Pues ahora todo el el escrutinio
Internacional que está ahora sobre
Nicaragua realmente funcione y tenga eco
con el gobierno de Ortega Bueno pues
vamos llegando al bloque final del
programa Ana María no hemos podido
restablecer la comunicación con Kevin en
la ciudad de Washington pero continuó
con usted para hacer la la conclusión
final de lo que puede significar este
hecho importante para la liberación de
estos 222 presos chicos en Nicaragua y
lo que sigue para ellos de aquí en
adelante y lo que sigue para el gobierno
de Daniel Ortega después de haber
realizado esta liberación de manera
unilateral su gran conclusión lo que
deja esta experiencia y lo que sigue
para las partes para Estados Unidos
involucrado en el proceso para los
liberados para la sociedad de
nicaragüense y para Ortega
a ver yo creo que este es un paso
importante también para fortalecer a
toda la comunidad nicaragüense en el
exilio es decir esta expulsión de los
doscientos veintidós simplemente
visibiliza nuevamente la situación de
Nicaragua y pone a Nicaragua bajo el
foco mundial de atención Entonces es de
aprovechar esto aprovechar a fortalecer
a la sociedad civil nicaragüense que
sigue ejerciendo presión desde el exilio
como menciono mucha Hay muchísimo
nicaragüenses en Costa Rica en México en
Estados Unidos y en otras partes del
mundo que están tratando de articular
esfuerzos para frenar el autoritarismo
que afecta grandemente a Nicaragua
entonces
la comunidad internacional debería y
debe apoyar los esfuerzos de estas
personas
así mismo continuar con los sistemas de
monitoreo como mencioné al inicio pues
la el consejo de derechos humanos y este
grupo de expertos presentará justamente
El Seis de marzo este informe pues
valdría la pena darle seguimiento a la
recomendaciones de este informe y que
Naciones Unidas pueda tener acciones
articuladas para aprovechar esta
coyuntura y que de esto pueda salir algo
positivo En beneficio de los derechos
humanos de la población nicaragüense
Pues esperemos que todos sean beneficios
de la sociedad nicaragüense de este de
la ciudadanía de este país
centroamericano por supuesto atentos al
resultado de ese informe que presentarán
el 6 de marzo y las recomendaciones que
esto puede hacer Ana María Yo le
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros aquí en el debate y por
habernos ayudado a hacer el análisis de
la situación de lo que significa para
este país para la situación política
para este nuevo capítulo de la crisis
que se abre en esa nación
centroamericana y lo que significa el
papel de Estados Unidos y también de la
comunidad internacional en todo este
proceso hoy el programa nos ha quedado
un poco cojo por temas técnicos pudimos
tener a Kevin solamente por unos minutos
por lo menos pudimos conocer un poco de
sus planes ahora en libertad en Estados
Unidos y lo que planea en su lucha
digámoslo así para seguir elevando su
voz y sus críticas contra el gobierno de
el presidente Daniel Ortega en Nicaragua
pues Seguiremos también el paso de lo
que vaya haciendo Kevin allí en Estados
Unidos y como este grupo de 222 personas
fueron llevadas a este país donde pueden
prácticamente Volver a comenzar de nuevo
les agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros Ana María Muchas gracias En
nombre de todo el equipo técnico Les
agradecemos la sintonía la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y la producción de invitados
estuvo a cargo de Tania Herrera
Recuerden que ustedes pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios y sus preguntas
a través de las redes sociales de France
24 y también pueden ver otros episodios
del debate en France 24.com sigan con
nosotros
[Música]